nancy fait du charme aux plaisanciers un
an avant son lancement officiel le port
ste catherine accueille dès cet été ses
premiers touristes fluviaux des
plaisanciers de tous pays viennent jeter
l'ancré nancy reste maintenant à les
convaincre de profiter de cette étape au
découvrir la cité stanislas le port de
plaisance de nancy peut d'ores et déjà
accueillir près de 100 bateaux ouvert
depuis trois mois il est pourtant encore
bien souvent désert il faut dire que
l'ouverture s'est faite avant même la
fin des travaux prévue pour l'an
prochain
bon moi j'apprécie c'est sur le port est
quand même chouette
bon c'est dommage que la capitainerie
n'est pas été prête pour pour cet été
parce que ça aura permis de plus
facilité pour les douches pour
vous l'avez linge
à part ça je pense que c'est importe qui
peut
rendre bien équipe qui occupe est
chouette actuellement le port ste
catherine est surtout fréquenté par les
allemands et les hollandais les
touristes qui reste peu et qui souvent
ne visite pas la ville c'est la raison
pour laquelle la municipalité a lancé
une offensive de charme en rendant
visite aux plaisanciers afin de les
inciter à sortir de leur bateau pour
aller en ville
je voulais vous remettre de la
documentation en
pour qu un policier blessé oui
on va
oui c'était infrastructures est très
difficile à mettre en place
il restera maintenant à apporter des
solutions qui seront une capitainerie
bien entendu une garde l'électricité
l'eau déjà l'eau existent l'électricité
aussi c'est pas bien en place encore les
sanitaires
et puis nous allons prévoir des
commerces de proximité n'est ce pas là
le port de plaisance fêtent en fait
partie de la campagne de ravalement de
la ville ainsi que des opérations de
relance du commerce local
un million huit cent mille francs c'est
le coût total de l'investissement
actuellement le séjour est encore
gratuit d'ici cinq ans pour le bordeaux
nancy sera l'un des plus importants de
l'est les habitués apprécient déjà ce
couple d'allemands a cost depuis dix ans
à nancy
c'est beaucoup mieux cette année
les allemands soudain nous mêmes aussi
de venir à nancy c'est vraiment très
très bien